The first step when approaching
any business problem
is business understanding.
Some questions you can ask to help
understand the business issues are.
What decisions need to be made?
What information is needed
to inform those decision?
And what type of analysis can
provide the information needed
to inform those decisions?
Typically, developing a mental model of
the business issue helps a great deal
in structuring the potentially
relevant information
needed to perform the analysis.
Let's review a specific business
problem to help illustrate
business issue understanding.
How much electricity capacity does
a utility company need to supply for
any given hour tomorrow?
First, let's discuss what
decisions need to be made.
In this scenario,
we're looking to answer this question so
the organization can decide how
to supply the needed power.
They'll need to predict whether or
not they'll have enough capacity.
So they can determine which
plants they can bring online or
if they need to purchase
electricity in the marketplace.
The critical information
that needs to be known
is how much electricity will be demanded
in each hour of the day tomorrow.
Unfortunately, this information is not
known at the time decisions need to be
made.
So the demand for each hour
tomorrow needs to be predicted.
Which will allow the company to make
appropriate decisions about what
plants to turn on and if they'll need
to buy extra electricity or not.
Therefore, we know that we need
a predictive analysis to help us obtain
the data to inform
the decision we need to make.
We don't have enough information at this
point to know the type of predictive
analysis without a better understanding
of the data that is needed and
the data we have available.